again i'm not trying to promote
misinformation i'm not trying to be
controversial
i've never tried to do anything with
this podcast other than just talk to
people and have interesting
conversations
joe rogan is weighing in after being
accused of spreading misinformation on
his podcast the joe rogan experience
i wanted to make this video first of all
because i think there's a lot of people
that have a distorted perception of what
i do maybe based on sound bites or based
on headlines of articles that are
disparaging it all started when neil
young pulled his music off of spotify
the platform that hosts joe's podcast in
protest after joe had two experts on his
show to discuss the novel coronavirus
pandemic the podcast has been accused of
spreading dangerous misinformation
specifically about two episodes one with
dr peter mccullough and one with dr
robert malone and they have an opinion
that's different from the mainstream
narrative i wanted to hear what their
opinion is shortly after neil removed
his music from the streaming service
joni mitchell followed suit even meghan
markle and prince harry who have a
partnership with spotify called for the
platform to make a change
i want to thank spotify for being so
supportive during this time
and i'm very sorry that this is
happening to them and that they're
taking so much heat from it on sunday
the 54 year old podcaster addressed the
controversy head on arguing that many of
the things we once thought of as
misinformation are now accepted as fact
i do not know if they're right i don't
know because i'm not a doctor i'm not a
scientist i'm just a person who sits
down and talks to people and has
conversations with them i'm not
interested in only talking to people
that
have one perspective in response to the
controversy spotify posted a lengthy
statement the streaming service says
they plan to add a warning on content
that discusses coven 19. and joe
he's down for that i don't know what
else i can do
differently other than
maybe
try
harder to get people with differing
opinions on right afterwards i do think
that that's important and do my best to
make sure that i've researched these
topics the controversial ones in
particular and have all the pertinent
facts at hand before i discuss them
and he promises to do better going
forward my pledge to you
is that i will do my best to try to
balance out these more controversial
viewpoints with
other people's perspectives so we can
maybe find a better point of view i
don't want to just show the the contrary
opinion to what the narrative is as for
neil young and joni mitchell
well joe says he's still a fan no hard
feelings towards neil young and
definitely no hard feelings towards joni
mitchell i love her too and he says he's
learned a lot from the whole thing if i
pissed you off i'm sorry and uh if you
enjoy the podcast thank you thank you
very much thank you to spotify thank you
all the supporters and and even thank
you to the haters because
it's good to have some haters it makes
you
reassess what you're doing and put
things into perspective and and uh i
think i think that's good too
you